i think you've been exposed to the idea
of a function at some point in your
mathematical career but what i want to
do in this video is explain it a little
bit more formally than you might be used
to and then relate it to some of the
concepts of vectors and linear algebra
that we've seen so far so a function
literally is so i'll write it like this
a function really is just a relation
between the members of one set and the
members of the other set so let's say i
have some set x
and for every set x i'm going to relate
or associate well sorry with for every
member of that set x i'm going to relate
that member to or associate that member
with another member of a set y
of a set y so if i imagine
that
that that is my set x
and that this is my set y
right there and y doesn't have to be
smaller that's just the way i drew it
the function is just a relation that if
i just take a member of my set x
so if i just take a member of it let's
say that's the member that i'm taking it
we're visualizing is at a point
this function will say okay you gave me
a member of x then i will give you a
member of y associated with that member
of x
so the function will say you give me
that then i will
map it
i will map it to
that member right there
i'll use the word map it and that's
really just means relating it to or
associating with another member of y and
if you give me some other
point right here
i'll relate to another member of y
i'll relate it
to another member of y right there i
might even relate it to the same member
of y and so this notation just says this
is a mapping from one set x and i'm
speaking in very general terms to
another set y and so you're probably
saying hey sal you know
this is very abstract how does this
relate to the functions that i've seen
in the past well let me let me just
write down a function you've probably
seen a lot in the past
you've seen people write or you've dealt
with f of x is equal to x squared how
would we write this in this notation
well this is a function assuming that
it's kind of the traditional way that
you see it
this function and actually let me well
let me just write
with the f i was going to write it with
the g of x just so that this doesn't
always have to be an f but i think you
get you get that idea in this case f
is a mapping from real numbers right the
real numbers are everything that i can
put in here and actually this is part of
the function definition i could
constrain this to just be integers or
just be even numbers or just be even
integers but this is part of the
function definition i'm defining the
function to be a mapping
from real numbers i'm saying you can put
any real number here and it's going to
map
it's going to map
to well it's going to map to real
numbers so in this case if x is real
numbers it's going to map to itself
which is completely legitimate
so if this is the real numbers and
obviously the real numbers would go off
in every direction forever but if this
is the real numbers this function
mapping is just taking every point with
f and mapping it to another point or
every point in r and mapping it to
another point in r it's taking every
point and associating with it it's
perfect square and i want to make a very
subtle notation when or at least in my
mind the first time that i got exposed
to functions i was thinking you give me
an x and i square it and i'm giving you
the square of x and that's true you are
doing that but at least the way my brain
worked i kind of thought it was i was
changing my x into another number and
you can maybe view it that way and that
might actually be the best way to view
it but the the mathematically the
mathematical definition i'm introducing
here is more than i'm associating i'm
associating x
i'm associating x with
x squared and this is actually another
way this is another function notation of
writing this exact same thing these two
statements right here this statement and
this statement are identical this
statement you've probably never seen
before but i i kind of like it because
it kind of shows the mapping or the
association more while this association
i kind of think that look you're putting
you're putting an x into a little you
know meat grinder or some machine that's
going to turn that's going to ground up
the x or square the x or do whatever it
needs to do to the x this notation to me
implies the actual mapping you give me
an x and then i'm going to associate
another number in real numbers called x
squared so it's going to be just another
point and just as a little bit of of
terminology and i think you've seen this
terminology before
the set that you are mapping from is
called the domain
and it's part of the function definition
i as the function creator have to tell
you that look where every valid input
here has to be a set of real numbers
now the the set that i'm mapping to
the set that i'm mapping to
this is called the codomain
codomain which is
and and i guess the the obvious question
that you're probably asking is hey sal
when i learned all of this function
stuff in in in algebra 2 or whenever you
first learn it you're like where did you
know we never use this codomain word and
actually i don't think it has a hyphen
in it but we never use that code domain
word we have this idea of range
you know i learned the word range when i
was in 9th or 10th grade how does this
codomain
relate to
range and this is it's a very subtle
notation so the codomain is a set that
you're mapping to in this example this
is the codomain
codomain in this example the real
numbers are the domain and the codomain
so the question is how does the range
relate to this so the codomain is this
is the set that can be possibly mapped
to you're not necessarily mapping to
every point in the co domain i'm just
saying that this function is generally
mapping from members of this set to that
set
the range
the range is the subset
let me write it this way it could be
equal to the codomain
it's some subset
a set is a subset of itself every member
of a set is also a member of its of of
itself so it's a subset of itself so
range is a subset of the codomain i keep
adding a hyphen there
or dash
is a subset of the codomain which the
function actually maps to
that
the function
actually maps to
actually
maps to
maps two so let me give you an example
let's say i define the function let's
say i define the function g
and it is a mapping
from the set of real numbers
well let me say it's a set it's a
mapping from r2
to r
so i'm essentially taking two tuples and
i'm mapping it to r and i will define
i define g i'll write it a couple of
different ways i could write so now i'm
going to take g of
let's say two values so i could say x y
or i could say x1 x2 let me do it that
way
g of x1
x2
is equal to well let's say it's always
equal to 2
it just always equals to 2. it's a
mapping from r2 to r but this is always
equals 2.
so what is our and let me actually let
me write it the other notation just
because you probably haven't seen this
much but i could write g
of
g maps any points x1 and x2
to the point
2. this is kind of this makes the
mapping a little bit clearer but just to
get the notation right what is our
domain
what is our domain
what's the real numbers that was part of
my function definition i said we're
mapping from the from r2
so my domain is r2 and i should actually
make that with that little line there
now what is my codomain
my co
domain
well my codomain is the set that i am
potentially mapping to and it's part of
the function definition this by
definition is the codomain so my
codomain is r
now what is the range of my function
what is the range
the range is the set of values that the
function actually maps to in this case
we always map to the value two so the
range is actually just the value two and
if we were to visualize this you know r2
is actually you know i wouldn't draw it
as a blurb i would draw it as the entire
cartesian space but i'm just
giving you kind of an abstract notion
that's r2 if i really had to draw r i
would draw it as some type of a number
line
actually let me do it that way just for
fun you don't normally see it written
that way but i could just draw r like
that's r2
and i could just draw r as some straight
line
so this is the set r
i could draw it like that as well but
let's just say it's a set r and my
function g
maps essentially maps any point over
here
to exactly the point
two
right two is just one little point in r
my function g takes any
any point in r two
any coordinate x you know this is some
point you know this could be the point
three
minus five whatever it is and it maps it
it always maps it to the point two in r
so if i dig that point it maps it to the
point two that's what g always does
so g
so g's co domain you could say it's all
of the real numbers but its range is
really just 2. now if i write the
example
if i if i say that
let me do another example that might be
interesting if i just write h
is a function that goes from
let's just say it goes from
r
to
and i'll be a little careful here h is
goes from r2 to r3 and i'll write
and i'll write here that
h of
x1
x2
is equal to so now i'm mapping i'm going
to a higher dimension space so i'm going
to say that that is going to be equal to
let's say my first
coordinate i could say an r3 or my first
component at r3 is x1
plus x2 let's say my second coordinate
is x2 minus x1 and let's say my third
coordinate is x2
times x1
now
what is
what is my domain and my range
and my co-domain so my domain by
definition
my domain by definition is this right
there my codomain by definition is r3
and notice i'm going from a space that
has two dimensions to a space that has
three dimensions or three components but
i can always associate some point with
an x1 x2 with some point in my r3 there
and now a slightly trickier question
here is what is the range can i always
can i always associate every point
every point maybe this wasn't the best
example because it's not simple enough
but can i associate every point in r3
is ever can every point in r3 so this is
my
codomain my domain was r2
now and my function goes from r2 to r3
so that's h and so my range as you can
see there's not it's not like every
coordinate you can express as
in this way in some way let me give you
an example for example clearly the term
i mean i could put some x1s and x2s here
and and figure it out let's do that
let's take our
h of
and let me use my other
let me use my other notation
let's say that i said h
and i wanted to
find the mapping from the point in r to
let's say the point 2
comma three
and then my function tells me that this
will map to the point in r3
this will map to the i add the two terms
so two plus three so it's five i'd find
the difference between x2 and x1 so 3
minus 2 is 1 and then i multiply the 2
6.
so clearly this will be in the range
this is a member of the range
i i shouldn't write like that i should
write it like this the member
of the range so for example the point
2 3 which might be right there
will be mapped to the three-dimensional
point it's kind of just drawn as a
two-dimensional blurb right there but i
think you get the idea would be mapped
to the three-dimensional point five one
six so this is definitely a member of
the range
now my question to you if i have some
point in r3 let's say i have the point
i'm doing a different color
let me say i have the point there let's
say that this is the point
let's say this is the point five
one
five one
zero
five one zero is this is this point a
member of the range it's definitely a
member of the co-domain it's in r3 it's
definitely in here and this by
definition is the codomain but is this
in our range
well if i take this has 5 has to be the
sum of two numbers
the one has to be the difference of two
numbers and then the zero would have to
be the product of two numbers and
clearly we know five is the sum and one
is the difference we're dealing with two
and three and there's no way that you
can get the product of those numbers to
be equal to zero so this guy
is not
not in
not in the range so the range would be
the subset of all of these points in r3
so there'd be a ton of points that
aren't in the range and there'll be a
smaller subset of r3 that is in the
range i want to introduce you to one
more kind of one more piece of
terminology when it comes to functions
these functions up here
this function that mapped from points in
r2 to r so it mapped its codomain was r
this function up here that is probably
the most common function you see in
mathematics this is also mapping to r
these these functions that map to r are
called scalar value or real value
depending on how you want to think about
it
but if they map to kind of a
one-dimensional space we call them a
scalar valued function or a real valued
function
so scalar
valued or maybe we could call it a real
valued function real valued function
which is pretty much all of the
functions that you've
probably dealt with up to this point in
your in your mathematical career unless
you've kind of taken some some vector
calculus whatever not now
the functions that map to that map to
subs that map to spaces or or subspaces
that have more than one dimension so if
you map to r or any subset of r you have
a real valued function or a scalar
valued function if you map to you know
rn where n is greater than one so if you
map to r2 r3 r4 r100 you're then dealing
with a vector valued function so this
last function that i define over here h
is a vector-valued
vector
valued
function
anyway i think you now have at least the
the the mathematical notational tools to
understand what i'm going to do than the
rest of this playlist and and hopefully
you found this reasonably useful